Speaker 1: We have another one of these.
I still consider these sad stories, but they
could be instructive.
They could be wake calls.
A police officer from San Francisco who was
suspended he was on leave for refusing the
COVID vaccine has died of COVID.
I am I am sick of watching people throw their
lives away, optionally, statistically speaking
and at the same time, contributing to this
sense of doom of are we ever going to get
out of this?
This is a horrible story.
California police officer dies of COVID while
on leave for missing vaccination deadline
Now the requirements work.
As of Friday, ninety seven point two percent
of the San Francisco Police Department were
in compliance with the city's vaccination
mandate.
But we have a specific story here of a San
Francisco police officer who was on leave
for missing the city's COVID vaccination deadline
has died after testing positive for the coronavirus,
according to a police union representative
and the officer's wife.
We're talking about Officer Jack Nice, who
had been on the force 17 years, the police
department said in a statement on its Facebook
page announcing his death.
Nice served in a variety of assignments throughout
his career, adding that he is survived by
many friends, coworkers and family members.
Chief Bill Scott confirmed to NBC News that
Nice, who was described as a widely respected
colleague, died Saturday at age 47.
Scott declined to comment about cause of death.
Nisa's wife, Melissa Nice, did say to the
San Francisco Chronicle that he had tested
positive for the virus last Tuesday.
His symptoms became so serious that she called
an ambulance to take him to a hospital on
Saturday.
She declined to say whether he was vaccinated
against COVID and said he was by his side,
which said she was by his side when he died.
Folks, statistically speaking, statistically
speaking.
Vaccinated people die.
Statistically speaking, this is someone who
would have had a much milder case if vaccinated.
The belief is that he's unvaccinated because
he was on leave for not meeting the vaccination
requirements.
Now, one could say, David, maybe he was vaccinated,
but he didn't want to have to provide the
dystopian 1984 proof of his vaccine to the
department, so he was suspended for that.
That's possible.
And it strikes me as extraordinarily unlikely.
These are not stories to gloat about.
These are stories where if we learn something
from them, maybe we can get something useful
out of them.
But these are sad stories.
I continue to see these as sad, and it is
another person, statistically speaking.
Growing our sense of doom.
Are we ever going to get out of this pandemic
and throwing their life away?
And it is really sad.
I mean, think about it.
He signed up to be a police officer.
You could be stabbed as a police officer.
You could be shot as a police officer, etc.
But a tiny needle, they're not going to do
that.
They're not going to do that.
So another one of these stories, and I hate
to see it.
I know there are people in the audience who
write to me and say, David, I have no sympathy
for these people.
I have no empathy for the loved ones that
are left behind.
I do.
Maybe it's my personal flaw.
But the real problem is, are we ever going
to get out of this if we continue to see this
sort of resistance, horrible, horrible stuff?